I love this one I chose the new Republic
as our principal source for this story
because it's funny and got a picture of
Rhonda Sanders right here and then it
says Ron DeSantis is now attacking the
Hyatt Regency because it hosted a drag
show the Florida governor has been
waging a war on drag and on lgbtq people
in his State they say Florida Governor
Ryan Sanders moved Tuesday to strip the
height Regency of its liquor license for
allegedly allowing miners to attend a
Christmas time drag show I love how they
do that allegedly there's pictures of
children there there's video of a drag
queen
with fake breasts shoving them into the
face of a child
there's there's children allegedly
and they say he's cracking down an lgbtq
rights it's the crazy thing is these
people by any stretch of the imagination
must be pedophiles because there's no
reason why they would lie about what
descendants actually did unless they
were pedophiles so is Rhonda Sanders
going after lgbtq people no he
explicitly said if you have minors at an
adult entertainment show you will lose
your liquor license you'd even threaten
them with the rest I'm gonna go one step
further and say right now Ron DeSantis
arrest these people I would like to see
State Police go to the Hyatt Regency
walk up to the manager confirm were you
the manager on the night of December I
think it was 27th or something 2022
during the performance of the drag show
in which children were present yes place
your hands behind your back you are
under arrest and we're going to have you
register as a sex offender because you
facilitated the whole thing then find
the employees who helped facilitate this
and they get charges as well for aiding
and abetting a a sex show in which
children were present you doing parents
too what about the performance it's it's
oh absolutely absolutely the thing is
he's targeting the height Regency so I'm
speaking in the context of the Hyatt
Regency
there's an interesting question about
the performers they're not the ones who
let in the children but
we'll see we'll see you see a child in
front of you you go walk up on them and
create a sex act exactly I think they're
culpable absolutely so those people but
I'm not sure they're residents of the
state they may have been passing through
in which case good luck getting federal
charges but if they ever step foot back
in there should be an arrest here's what
really bothers me about this story is
that there's photos of this I don't I
don't want to show all the photos I
think YouTube might get us in trouble if
I show you like right here down at the
bottom of the screen uh why can't I see
it on the
that's weird oh I guess the mouse
doesn't appear normally it does well on
the bottom of the screen there's a
picture of a drag queen shoving their
chest into a child's face and uh we just
you know try and move away from that one
because I don't think we can actually
show that
what bothers me is that Rhonda Santos
only is taking away their liquor license
so the response is if you host a sex
show where you invite children we'll
take away your ability to sell beer
don't you think that he's kind of
baiting him I think okay you take their
liquor license you dare them to do it
again and the second time you send the
slot team you frog March them out in
Chains and you alert the media why the
second time because the government never
wants to jump in the first time with
everything they never throw everything
at it the first time I remember a story
about a guy who put grow lights in an
empty house and then a bunch of I was a
DEA agents stormed into the building
only to find nothing was in it he was
live streaming a sting operation and his
point was that they were going to come
in with no war into a house that did
nothing wrong yet right now we're
supposed to cheer for Rhonda santis
and he's like I took away their liquor
license now when they have sex shows for
children they'll have to be sober am I
supposed to be happy about that I'll
tell you I guess a little bit I'll take
baby steps rather than no steps we've
done nothing up to this point yeah we
haven't even stopped him from doing
anything so at least this take away
their revenue stream you're costing them
money
right and and if it's the if the threat
is the next time they will get cuffed
and stuffed I'd like to see it someone
said this is the over this is the
Overton window being shifted first they
do literal nothing then people complain
and they say we'll take away their
liquor license they can still operate
they can still sell uh um you know shows
at their Event Center they can still
have people come into the uh you know
the the restaurant order food you can
still rent rooms at the Hyatt no worries
okay I'm shouting out right now to my
friends in Miami who know the DeSantis
crew let's send in a SWAT team why why
should the Hyatt Regency be concerned
about their liquor license when their
principal business is selling hotel
rooms but if they operate a food and
beverage business liquor tends to be one
of those that's the high margin that's
margin so I mean I think what's
happening is they're trying to scare the
Hyatt Regency into not accepting a
contract from this group anymore and
that'll just send them to another venue
which then I guess will continue to
chase about it doesn't seem like the
most effective strategy to stopping them
you guys know that we've been to
Congress now a couple times they have a
Subway in the uh which building were we
in I don't know there's a Subway imagine
if a member of Congress did something
illegal so they went and said we're not
going to let that Subway operate anymore
and I'll show these corrupt members of
Congress they're going to be like okay
I'll go across the street to get Subway
so if you're staying at the Hyatt
Regency you just get drunk across the
street you rent your room their
principal business is completely
unaffected I gotta say look I I get it
some action is good to try and stop the
Overton window shift that's allowing
this this grooming that's happening but
all they're really doing it seems to me
is throwing red meat at people who are
upset about this and then saying cheer
for the nothing that I have done I have
done nothing at all to stop this quite
nothing I have hurt the bottom line of
one height location by seven percent if
that I'm willing to bet alcohol
comprises a fraction of a percentage of
their revenue they don't care the right
does nothing yeah there you go period
they never do they they do it's all for
show they don't they're just as you know
just as interested in virtue signaling
as anyone else
um if this is considered action
then the left has nothing to fear from
the right agreed
to know more about Murray and Peter who
presented the drag queen Christmas like
I I want to know what the production
company is doing because they're
probably operating I mean typically
hotels bid for contracts and then
whichever one works out a deal with the
organization that wants to book the
space you know moves forward with
contracts so who else considered who
else tried to get this drag queen Sergio
if we can't have it at the Hyatt where
is it going now I think that's what
bothers me the most like yes it's not
enough of an action from DeSantis but
partially because it keeps the head on
the snake we're not really stopping it
from Just migrating somewhere else
across town let's get citizens given
tips for every drag show coming up and
dare DeSantis not to react to the next
one you know I don't care if adults want
to have a drag show if they want to do
burlesque if they want to do Go-Go
dancing if they want scantily clad men
and women standing you know swinging
around on poles that's fine just no kids
if the right wants to do something about
it they should be putting the performers
that are that are performing for
children in jail Rhonda Santos if you
really believed these people if you
really thought this was true would be
he'd have the D.A issue arrest warrants
for these individuals and upon their
return to the state for any reason they
would immediately be arrested well I'm
sure a bunch of them are local it's not
even it was a touring thing but I'm sure
they invite local talent in like that's
pretty normal I'm confident these shows
I think wanted to do something this is a
37 State touring show I'm not sure it
was a local thing I think it was a
touring are there any other states that
have laws has anybody else passed Texas
Texas no no Texas had a a drag show
where they were presenting sex in front
of children and the police said I refuse
to get involved
so it's like look man I understand that
we're looking for Hope where we can find
it and a lot of people they don't want
to be black pilled but if I'm supposed
to cheer for Ron DeSantis for having
done the bare minimum literally the
least he could possibly do about this
I guess it's better than the rest of the
states that do literal nothing like Greg
Abbott but uh yeah I'm just
unenthused
not optimistic about where this is all
going well shaming helps so I'll stop
public shaming on it tomorrow that's a
fair point I would love to see I mean
the video of a drag queen being hauled
out of a bar in handcuffs would go a
long way towards throwing a little
gasoline I honestly think the manager of
the establishment that facilitated a sex
show for children should be brought out
wearing their nice little button-up
shirt and tie with their pens in their
pocket being like I don't understand why
I'm being arrested I operate an
establishment and then as they're being
brought out the police can say he
operated a sex show for children and
they'll go whoa jail and make sure that
the inmates that he shares that he
shares uh another jail with make sure
they know because I don't care about any
of that weird stuff man just
have him register as a sex offender and
that's see that's a huge threat right
there because they're not doing anything
no they did but that's a great one
that's a great tool right there if you
operate a sex show because it used to be
10 years ago 15 years ago a drag show
was dudes in ball gowns singing Abba yes
right right you know now they're wearing
g-strings and shoving their groins faces
simulating birth and abortion that's
just so different that's that's a
completely different thing it's not
burlesque it's not a drag show it's a
perverted section
they point out in the complaint that the
one of the videos played actually shows
genitals it actually shows the nudity
and things like that which is crime so
let's I'm with you dude I think the
let the shaming begin there we all have
voices right okay there's two things
that I want to say first of all I agree
that that stigma is not used enough
nowadays like it it's like so social
shaming is used for for basically for
the wrong things essentially and there
should be more shaming from people on
the right which speaks to Tim's point
and and uh Matt Walsh's point about you
know being more aggressive I think is
probably a better way to describe it but
they they were saying be more mean but
shaming is good and it's it's what you
should use in place of legislation so
I'm not a big fan of of having like I'm
not a big fan of SWAT teams and stuff
like that generally so I think that it's
better to have Society shame people and
and try to discourage uh Behavior you
know
um so I think that that's the spot let's
go if you're at a drag show take the
license plates fill them out drop them
then you're dropping names docs them
online no no no you can't well you can't
say that yes but but none of that weird
stazi Soviet stuff we have laws on the
books they cited the laws on the books
and they're doing nothing about it I
don't want to I like I I don't I don't
care for this right on your neighbor's
stuff we shouldn't have to we should
have a society that enforces its own
laws when the those laws exist instead I
get it you know we got a super chat here
Rocky says the point-of-point liquor
license is to show the smaller
establishments that it's serious thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time